hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel with today I am finally
allowed to talk to you guys about ghosts
of Tsushima I've been playing this game
for probably the past two weeks I think
do you have to disclose PlayStation
provided me with a code and I took
questions from you guys on the 30th of
June apparently so I'm basically gonna
read out some of our top comments here I
probably won't get to all 3000 but I
think it this is a good way to sort
through what you guys want to have
answered the most so the first question
from NCR ranger says displaying is the
ghost with samurai effect the story
greatly or other they just ways of
changing up the gameplay uh no your
combat approach does not affect the
story and there are a lot of different
combat approaches as well I don't even
feel like reducing it to just the ghost
in just the samurai is necessarily fit
for anyone who doesn't know that much
about close to Tsushima you do have the
option to play as ghosts and everyone
will call you the ghost which is
actually pretty cool but that really
just means the stealth approach which a
lot of the times during the story is
forced there ah and I know people hate
this order failed stealth missions
pretty frequently I actually didn't have
a problem with them in this game but do
want to point it out as I know that's
the thing that some people don't like
and then samurai I guess is when you're
being more aggressive but they're also
like different stances the watersense
will work best against enemies that have
shields there's another stance for
people with swords so that there are a
lot of different options where combat is
concerned I do want to say just off the
bat and I guess I'm really curious to
see reviews when they come out which
will be the same time this video goes up
I expect there to be a lot of people who
are critical of the combat but I think
that they will be misguided I was really
bad at the chromatic fest I just didn't
pay quite enough attention to caring and
dodging in the way that I should have
and it's easy to not pay attention to
that stuff because while those
assistants that are in a souls like for
more frequently seen in games that are
really punishing and will literally kill
you if you don't do those things because
ghosts of Tsushima has those same
systems and the combat relies on them a
lot but doesn't actually kill you if you
don't do them it's easy to fall into
this habit of just mashing square and
triangle and trying to kill enemies
which makes the combat kind of not fun
so I am sort of expecting to see some
reviewers tomorrow or youtubers or
whoever else speak a bit negatively
the combat if they didn't Perry and
George the way that they should have if
they never figured out that that's the
way that you should be playing the game
once you do it is a very good pairing of
feeling like it goes to the samurai
because he's slick and you're agile and
you're Foss but you also do a lot of
damage and do have different stances to
swap between to do that there's also
like moments where I just straight-up
played as a nacho there's an archery
outfit that increases your abilities
when it comes to Autry but yeah I did
want to know that's one thing that I
think is gonna be really interesting to
see how differently people talk about
physios does the open world feel empty
at times no oh my god does it size an
amount of its content justify each other
um I feel like this question is probably
coming from the perspective of people
who were kind of worried about it
feeling a little bit too much like
Assassin's Creed and I was worried about
that too when I saw the state of play it
does and doesn't but the open-world is
more like breath of the wild than it is
like really anything else that I've ever
played it is it's almost like breath of
the wild got a sequel I was gonna say I
don't know if it captures the same level
of wonder of the open world of breath in
the wild but it actually in some cases
kind of does so the wind mechanic which
we've seen in gameplay rules can get
very aggressive sometimes but it does
rule it basically means that there's no
way points in the game whatever you set
your next objective to on the map the
wind will sort of softly guide you in a
certain direction but there are also
birds that show up and I highly
recommend you follow the birds I
followed them whenever they see them
there are foxes that show up and they
will kind of lead you to occasionally
these little like climbing puzzles that
have scattered around the walls to give
you an opportunity to do different
things that will you know level up your
skill sets but it's mostly just that the
way that those things show up and the
fact that this game is so freakin
beautiful in terms of the sky and the
trees and even just the way like hills
and valleys flow against each other like
oh my god I would have got through this
game a lot faster if I didn't have to
keep stopping just to take photos of
stuff which is also very easy the
built-in camera is so cool but I
honestly would keep shaking my head
those two Tsushima is open-world because
I find it so stunning because they also
just like go stylish with it so while in
plenty of ways it does look realistic
they also you know sometimes we'll just
have an area that's been burned that it
is completely black rather than still
having maybe I don't know the dhobi
Brown or something
they just completely 100% lean into the
style and that means you know riding
through areas it's sunset with red
leaves falling everywhere it butterflies
it it's just so ah and I highly
recommend that for anyone who's picking
up this game you don't just run through
the main quest I think any time you find
a tail that's new you on the weight of
the main quest or you see a butt or a
fox like I said follow those things play
through the story slowly I think and I
say that in large part because I think
that the world is actually the strongest
part of this game I think the story is
okay and I feel like it would just
really suck to someone to play it just
going objective to objective and missing
all the cool stuff that the world has to
offer there are absolutely similar
genetic pots of the open world like
clearing out camps does feel you know
like that Assassin's Creed 4 is staple
and they're all just patrols of enemies
that will try to fight you on site
pretty much as well as animals that just
seem to come upon you in the wild he'll
try to find you again it feels a very
far cry in that way
he also said how does it differ itself
from other open world action-adventure
games gameplay wise I mean honestly I
feel like the way that the open wealth
functions and drives you towards things
is a very good answer for that too santé
be said does the combat feel as
satisfying as it looked in the trailers
it can obviously we already touched on
this a little bit but getting a perfect
parry is always really satisfying but
there are things that like make that a
little bit odd which is mostly to do
with enemy AI like I feel like sometimes
I will be waiting to parry an enemy
rather than just hacking at them and one
thing that I wish just happened was the
enemy AI just doesn't seem to attack you
that much necessarily there are several
enemy types that have unblockable
attacks those guys will attack you
plenty and one use that era thing that I
kept doing which started to get annoying
is that dodge is circled once and roll
is circled twice if an unblockable
attack comes at you
you can hit them in the back if you
accidentally push press it twice which I
kept doing because I'd be panicked about
being hit you roll and then you'll way
too far out of range to be able to
attack them I sort of wish those with
different buttons so that I didn't keep
having that problem but yes aside from
that minor issue and some enemies just
taking a lot of hits to kill yeah it is
really satisfying
Carolee parents ed is someone who really
enjoyed playing breath of the wild but
doesn't want to play at Dark Souls s
came is this game accessible to story
loving game is there is an easy
difficulty I have not tried it but it
does definitely exist so I'm gonna guess
yes Stuart Little
given the invasion of Tsushima was a
real event his game seemed to try to
incorporate real history into its story
oh do things that maybe educate the
player on the events of biggest since I
don't know anything about that event I'm
definitely not the right person to ask
question - can you develop both the
samurai and ghost play styles of builds
equally and alternate for effectiveness
are you kind of driven to pick the one
main one you can absolutely alternate
between both lone wolf won 5-3 said does
it feel like Assassin's Creed or it's
entirely a fresh experience it doesn't
feel anywhere near as much like
Assassin's Creed as I expected it to I
think there are touches of Assassin's
Creed in there but Bailey if anything I
feel like Assassin's Creed valhalla kind
of needs to be worried about this game
it's funny it was announced that
Assassin's Creed Valhalla has like what
was the basically like origin of rap
battles when one goes to Tsushima you
can make haikus so watch out Valhalla it
doesn't feel like like samurai
Assassin's Creed it it feels a lot more
like its own thing than that official is
the open-world organic like right at
redemption - actually yes Red Dead
Redemption - when it comes to quests is
a really good parallel I think the way
that you happen upon quests I had a guy
run up to me and tell me he needed help
because his family was being murdered
and so I journey don't have to find them
and it turns out they were dead he was
coward he ran away and maybe I was too
late I don't know but yeah that's that
kind of approach of like people just
coming up to you and engaging you in
something well maybe you just like
happen upon them while they I'm not
playing the flute does feel a fair
amount like like protector version - I'm
skipping some of these because I feel
like I've already touched on them mister
Bo
does the lack of any waypoints and only
using the wind to find you'll wait away
you need to go get at all ties somewhat
frustrating or is it pretty easygoing
it's extremely easy going the only time
and I found it difficult was in a
particular side quest which there are a
number of where you basically get a map
that you can pull up I believe with the
touchpad that is literally images in
game and you have a little suckle when
you basically need to find a specific
thing based on that hand-drawn map the
wind won't guide you in that kind of
instance and the world feels pretty big
so those took me longer than they should
have in some cases for sure because the
wind isn't that a help and maybe you
depend on it but no generally it's very
obvious way you need to go it's really
smart if any gameplay mechanic is taken
from this game and put into other things
it's that win mechanic because it's not
always just like aggressive white lines
sometimes it's also just the direction
of the leaves fall in the direction you
need to go so it's like the world is
just kind of like feeding you slowly
towards the thing you need to go towards
it's just I love it it's so good there
are a couple of other just like general
traversal things that this game does
that I like like if you are walking
alongside an NPC you actually don't need
to control where you're going you can
just hold the stick forward and you will
automatically track at the same sort of
speed and go the same direction as then
which works because this game actually
does give you quite a lot of story bits
and dialogue told through just segments
while you kind of walk next to another
character but yeah I think it does that
with horses too also similar to Red Dead
Redemption to grand loss and asked one
an only question is the main character
compelling
I like Jen a lot and that's actually
something that I think is worth noting
is the story is fine I feel like I said
that before I don't find myself super
attached to the story of goes to
Tsushima the characters however I really
like virtually every character
I was super interested in and and really
enjoyed getting to know and spending
time with because you do a lot of
walking next to a character or writing
next to a character and kind of lighting
that backstory there are betrayals and
twists and turns and everyone has their
own circumstances and their own
motivations and they don't feel like
they just exists because you exist in a
way that is totally a credit to the
writing team
Jhin being a protagonist yeah yeah I
like gin yeah he's great Patrick asked
how does horse movement feel and do you
have freedom in how you attack an enemy
base horse move it's great really good
you don't like randomly run into a tree
and then everything falls apart no it's
actually quite seamless there's also
this one minor touch that I just really
like what if you try to make your horse
go faster or like to canter or gallop or
whatever
it always rears a little bit and makes a
sound before speeding up I don't know
that's just kind of like an odd nice
touch that I really like you have
freedom and how you attack an enemy base
yeah you can go in hot out if you want
to one of my favorite things in this
game is a mechanical to stand off
basically if someone's approaching you
and you're approaching and you haven't
quite engaged in combat yet but it looks
like you you know you're not stealth in
your way in you press triangle and then
the two of you will was like a sort of a
mini cutscene you will walk up to each
other and you have to then hold triangle
and wait for them to look like they're
going to attack you it's almost like
drawing your guns like if cowboy x
except with swords so you have to wait
until the exact moment and sometimes
I'll try to fake you out you have to
wait till the exact moment would have
actually drawn the sword to try to
attack you and then you let go and
you'll kill them oh it's so satisfying
every single time I was like hell yes I
did that but there are also things like
bees you could shoot a business and then
bees will come out and try to attack
people I did let a bear out of a cage in
one particular settlement and it only
tried to kill me I couldn't lure it to
kill the enemy AI like Fakhri which was
kind of a Bhama you can also stop fires
or you can kill absolutely everyone if
you want to it is totally up to you yeah
Peter de lisle said is a gameplay loop
feel like one I could get all quickly if
at all also what games would you most
closely compare the gameplay feel to the
gameplay loop yes I think can get a
little bit old but I think that more
depends on how you play where the
open-world is concerned like if you want
going off to the same quests over and
over again there's enough variety and
the missions are varied and interesting
in a way that it shouldn't feel
repetitive to you and that's basically
how I played it but for people who are
going and just like clearing out the
settlements or just going through the
main story I can imagine for those
people it will feel like
gameplay loop so yeah it's very much on
the way that you digest this game really
I have one gripe with the storytelling
which i think is actually just like more
of a personal issue that I have I don't
know that necessarily everyone else will
have this problem with it this is just
something that I've never liked in video
games ever since Metal Gear Solid 4 it's
just been a thing that I just don't like
which is there'll be a cutscene and then
it'll be like walk from here to here and
then another cutscene but why have me
walk for the 10 seconds in between I
always find that like that pick up
put-down feeling to be a little bit
annoying and that does happen in the
story missions in this game and I think
that again that is a personal issue I
don't think everyone else generally has
that problem it's just something that
I've grown to dislike otherwise no I
feel like this setting plays such a
significant part and the gameplay would
consistently feeling fresh it really
feels like you again I just want to say
like breath of the wild like you're
constantly on the brink of a discovery
that nobody else has ever had in their
entire lives like you're seeing this
location for the first time and it's the
most beautiful thing you've ever seen
even graveyards like it's just stunning
I also did swap to the Kurosawa mode
pretty regularly and I would do this
kind of based on the vibe so there was
one instance where I was leading up to
sort of a boss fight it was a sidequest
maybe more of a mini boss and it was
raining and the fight was like around
these trees that had these white leaves
and I think there was some lightning so
I turned it on and did the whole mode oh
sorry the whole fight in Kurosawa mode
which means it gets grainy and the audio
sounds so different sounds older and
obviously it's all black and white for
anyone who hasn't seen that and I loved
that I wish it were a quick eruption
like there was some way for me to like
quickly press a button to swap to that
mode but it is really easy to find in
the in the menu but yeah I did that
plenty it and I loved that in terms of
what games I would compare the gameplay
feel to I think the open wilds breath of
the wild Red Dead Redemption to the
closest of course there is some
Assassin's Creed in there
plumb bat is like maybe Sakura mixed
with Batman also a little bit of
Assassin's Creed in there
and a bill said the trailer with the
Japanese video seemed to be out of sync
or two characters lips is it noticeable
in the final game yeah I played in
Japanese which means that the sync is
off because the animations are English
so for anyone who plays English which I
think I'm going to do for my second
playthrough then the sync will be
perfect it's just the opposite of what
we're used to saying obviously if you
see a Japanese film that's dubbed in
English I feel like I don't notice that
as much so it's cuz it's dubbed the
other way around
yes it is absolutely noticeable because
they are speaking in English but you are
hearing Japanese and also I do want to
say voice acting is fantastic I'm very
very into it Fredrik sim said do you
feel like a samurai while playing
meaning does the game fully emerge you
um do I feel like a samurai no I feel
like Jin like I feel like it's a lot
more about this character specifically
and being this character than it is
about just being a samurai Jin is
definitely a fleshed out character and
yeah there's a lot of cool stuff that
you can do with him that does make it
feel a little bit silly yes you do see
his naked butt frequently actually when
you take a little ball and you get an
option of what to think about and it'll
raise your HP and sometimes think about
you dad or your uncle
but all of those options but there's
also like you can change your outfits
all the time which I feel like I do a
lot I would swap between them pretty
frequently there's one that makes you
better with the bow I feel like that I
would often swap to when I I knew I was
gonna be doing more range stuff and I
really liked the boat combat to multiple
different kinds of bows as well you can
upgrade all of your weapons you can dye
your clothing you say flowers to buy new
hats so in that way you know collecting
flowers to buy a new straw hat from a
guy who looks like the happy mask
salesman doesn't really make you feel
like samurai it is silly and
light-hearted sometimes but certainly
yeah I felt like Jin which means yes it
immersed me in feeling like Jin I do
also want to note there was something
very nice about playing this game off -
playing the lost of his pot to you and
that it is a lot more pleasant and happy
however you do still have to kill
dogs also in Deadly Premonition to which
I'm also currently playing you have to
kill dogs all these video games right
now just making us kill dogs and it's
such a bummer I feel like I've pretty
much answered them all now all the
questions that are left are kind of
related to the same stuff but I'm also
thinking that based on the questions
that I'm getting here I mean I guess I
felt this way too so it makes sense
people don't know that much about this
game so maybe when I published this
video and the review and logo goes up if
you guys have more questions because
you'll be seeing more gameplay at that
point I'll do like a live Q&A so yeah
feel free to ask more questions in the
comments of this in any case because
yeah a lot of the questions here are
very very similar and I think that
pretty much covers it let me know if you
guys have any more questions I'll see
you guys next up like